est-ce que tu aimerais incarner un jour
James Bond au cinéma oui tu es optimiste
pour l'avenir oui tu es retourné à
l'Opéra depuis intouchable oui tu
aimerais que tirailleur soit montré dans
les écoles oui l'argent fait-il le
bonheur non tu regardes tes anciens
films oui si on me proposait un
intouchable 2 et même pas fini tu as
déjà triché lors d'un examen oui est-ce
que tu pourrais refaire service
après-vente non est-ce que tu as déjà
regretté d'avoir joué dans un film oui
est-ce que tu viens plus aux soirées si
j'y vais toujours parce que le cinéma
pollue trop non la vie est-elle
meilleure aux États-Unis oui jouer en
peul est-ce que c'est mieux que jouer en
anglais
je sais pas tirailleurs est-ce que c'est
le film qui te tient le plus à cœur je
sais pas tu pourrais faire un one man
show un jour non est-ce que tu aimerais
rejouer dans un Marvel oui très fort et
oui il restait 10 secondes j'ai même
plus de questions